fill the link
a fifth NBA championship would represent
what to you a fifth NBA championship
would represent
who
a fifth one
to even think about five is crazy but I
think a fifth NBA championship like
I think if you if you had any doubt
it's just no more doubt but I already
feel like the dog is gone it's gone
it'll represents even less less than
that okay
okay give me a good media answer here
you know you media Draymond don't give
me don't give me Warriors dream
unanswered here
the team that will give the Warriors the
most problems this season is
the team that will give Warriors the
most problems this season
the Brooklyn Nets
because they can shoot
they can shoot yeah they can defend
they can play in half court
they can play in transition
want to make it an ISO game they can do
that just as good as anybody if not
better than everybody
they got the pieces
now
you know when the going gets tough you
got to see how you respond and react to
that yeah
they got the pieces
I like it okay a player you hate
matching up against the most is a player
that I hate matching up against the most
I don't really hate matching up against
anyone but I would say the player that
gives me the most trouble
is Darius Garland he's so Herky jerky I
love that answer at like
I hate guard DG I think that's the
player that like
I'm like ah
I'll guard him and I'm always sit on the
guard and I'm never not I'm never
ducking no switch Yeah
but you got to be willing to live with
something you're not just about to like
eat too early yeah and calves are fun
and I love Evan Mobley ah Evan mobile is
a stuff oh no yeah like he's gonna be
one of them ones for real absolutely I
really like Evan Evan Mobley one and one
for certain all right three more another
Grizzlies Warriors playoff would be
another Warriors win
I knew you're gonna see
I love that matchup I just think it's so
much that's so cool right like it's fun
it's you know point guards jaw young
Opera come point guard or staff blah
blah blah
the Rivalry
well the other thing I think that's
interesting about that whole thing too
is like fans don't understand that
basketball players this is basketball
like you and jaw don't dislike each
other you know what I mean like there's
a very strong mutual respect that exists
between you two the fans are like oh my
God they hated each other they're gonna
match up it's like no it's it's
basketball they understand the
competition of it and they love that but
then they move on so don't hate them at
all actually
got a lot of love yeah a lot of love and
respect just how you carry himself how
he like I said the one of the biggest
things for me is how he make those guys
believe in themselves and him like in
their team like just how he make them
believe that's a that's a skill yeah and
it takes respect to do that so I got I
got a lot of love yeah no they would all
like run through a wall for him this
year's MVP will be
this year's MVP will be
hmm that's an interesting one
it also might be early it gets a little
it is early yeah and the reason I think
it's early is because
I mean let's face it right like your
team has to do well and there's just
there's so many teams just like
jumbled and like no separation
that one team could take off like I
think Steph Steph has played at an MVP
level but our record does not
state that currently but we're also not
so far off to where that can't change
and then if that does change could Steph
be the MVP but if things stood as they
stand today I think who's who will be
MVP is probably Joker again like which
is wild it's wild but the stuff that is
he about to average a triple double and
no it's wild all right it's wild
I mean he he incredible I think it'll be
him again because they're winning
they're in first place in the West
um and his numbers got better yeah
last one
what if you were not an NBA player you'd
be
if I was not an NBA player
well I'm not going to be an NBA player
at some point soon I mean not soon but
eventually yeah
I'm closer to the end than I am the
beginner put it that way yeah
um
I wanna I'm gonna do a lot in television
and film and so not just
um
Sports analysts work like I I absolutely
love that not just podcasting but I want
to do
some different things in television and
film as well and so
possibly a director oh I love that being
behind the camera producing writing and
directing absolutely I think I think
directing people is one of my strengths
though and so if I can
learn that business
I think I can apply some things about
leadership that I already understand
yeah and um you know I have great people
helping me learn that business yeah you
know a really good friend of mine Deion
Taylor who
my wife introduced me to him and his
wife Roxanne and just like she's an
actress right yes and just like
different people like that that are
really helping me along this journey
um and teaching like I'm I'm very
thankful for and it's a business that I
really
really do love